今日はドクター始めた会社でつがいます
違いなだけでたいですね今前得な始めたという実験今日やっていこうと思います
ちょっと今回の実験ちょっと僕もちょっと怖いんですドキドキしてます
誰でも簡単に幻覚を見る方法があるらしいです
[音楽]
強いあのドクターはじめちょっとビビってますこれ一から教えてもらったことで県など
が危険じゃないのかちょっと僕よくわかんない状態で今からになるんで
ただ本当にこれが危ないなんかどうか確かめるのドクターはじめの実験の醍醐味といえ
さすがやっていこうとボル gantz フェルト効果という誰でも簡単に幻覚を見る
方法があるそうです gantz フェルト効果初耳ですねげっ
えっやばいやばいけどこれ大丈夫へ強いやばい型ザクドラッグなしで幻覚現場を体験
する超簡単な方法20分で感覚がぶっ飛び世界観が変わる
かよ大丈夫安全などからちょっと確認させていただきますねえええ
怖いよ
なっハやってみましょうざっくり説明する
女を白い紙で覆い why 社ドイツを聞くことで感覚遮断状態を作るそうすると幻覚
や幻聴タイプにできるらしいです
なるほどああ
ああなるほどメンバー高熱国も子供の時あったんですけどもね県で出るときなんか献上
桃価格にアフィなったりしたことがあったじゃないですかああいうのにたものが
ジャンプせると効果と言うらしいです
今日はイメージ内服で実験とかもしてんだ大丈夫そうですねたぶん大丈夫です阿南第犯
的なものじゃないしたが安全かどうか等かありませんよねってだけ必要なもの
宇津井白地の神化粧前に使うこと
ゴムバンドハサミテープホッチキス後紐であと30分以上連絡するホワイトメンズ
もしくは雑音が流れる youtube ビデオノイズキャンセリングヘッドフォン
なるほど京都つプロでいい気がするんでこれやってみましょう解体でこれだけあれば
出来るらしいですねべそうですねでは早速やっていこうと思いますちょっとこれ適当な
大きさに切りますと
多分まず白い紙をアイマスでぐらいの1009らしいですね私の命がここに来ると思う
んで変なクリーチャーにコットンを貼り付けていくらしいです
ん
さらに光が入っちゃダメらしいのでこういうカフェでちょっと目の部分っています端
からの光が入るのでこれ肌の部分もなんか光が入らないにするらしいです
あなたはほぼつけて完成ぽいですね
ブードゥーの
ん
たいときで一応か運営しましたこれでもつけて彼が入らない状況を作り出せしまいます
ということですねはいで年付従来の光ぽいが入って来なかったですちょっと補強しよう
簡易トイレ完成しましたこれがガン2セット効果を得るために必要なマスク
光を遮るものですこの後どうすれば幻覚を見るかというとあー2分でつないな
ヘッドフォンとともにアイマスを捜索して
仰向けになり自分の感覚を無にするようにしてみると
10分から30分後に
くるらしい
えーっを開いておいて準備は整ったんで早速やってみようと思いますノイズキャン
セリングされるイヤホンつけて
うわぁ強いもうの油圧入ってますホワイトノイズですね
すげー
めっちゃめっちゃホワイトノイズの道がありましたこれをずっと流し続けますへ怖いよ
なんか怖い
でここから仕掛けもはれるんでしょ山10分から30分間に効果が出るらしいんで僕は
とりあえず分になるような感覚で頑張ります親父に違う実験開始
はいはいはい
はい言っていきまーす
何かあったら言いますねまつげが長くて痒いです
[音楽]
ん
なぁなぁ
必要せめてましたうんだめだねちゃっ実験失敗ですこれめっちゃだめだですよねー
基本中すぎて出来ましたよくないよくないですよねーもう一度チャンスを下さい
づぎわけないようにキュンちょっとにゃんじゃあねっなくてちゃんと動きますもちろん
れないように頑張らせていただきますでおやすみなさいアティ
じゃだめなんだって本当に
ん
[音楽]
うん
ん
ちょっとあの外が鍵確認してきますこれやばいの多い
聞いただけなんだけどやってる時を刺されたらやばいのでこの時これやって思ったのは
マジでやってる時好きだだけだから
ふうにお礼を倒すな今だよってくらい好きだだけなんでちょっとやるときマルイ気を
つけてもいいです
すごい人だりって言います
このっ売ってこいけます
凄い件増加
ここはすごい
めっちゃ周りがザワザワガヤガヤしてる
[音楽]
こ
船が出航するの通りこえタイマー子
[音楽]
このあ
大
きたきたきたきたきたきたきたーーーー
わあすごいすごい
うわぁガッツリくるなこれ
いいいい
[音楽]
わー
はすごいわー虹色ですね20学校
を集まっ
では厚はンってあってかぜひ高
すごいすごい万華鏡みたいな感じですね
[音楽]
お願いだからああセイヴァー
全然大丈夫なんですけど全然大丈夫なんですけどちゃんと言えたわー
すごこれ成功ですねいやブッ飛んだねぇ
すごいちゃんとぶっ飛んだ何でも全然そんな体に害があるとかなんかすごい気分が悪く
なっていうわけじゃなくてただ12最初めっちゃ怖かったですね
耳もあれだし目もわからなかったからなんかネットでも調べてるんですけどみんなが見
てる奴通りの奴が一緒とか切らないな何か僕が再現する
なんかすごく伝わりにくいと思うんですけど mother 2の銭湯の背景ですね
宣伝伝わると思うけど何でもなんか紫長の虹色だったんです根崎[ __ ]虹色の何か
欲しい方ポイントかねバイクてあってちょっとずそれから英語で色が変わってるんです
けどもそこに向かってなんか色んな
紫っぽいんで白を白せてけど聞いてくる家でもずっと繰り返されてましたね僕の
みたい幻覚はすごい本当に最初ただのなんか
グレーっぽい grep おいしい梅まっさらのとこだったんですけどもぼーっと
ずっと見てたらなんかだんだん元関してこうしました
幻聴はもうちょっとよくわかんないさあの僕の耳がおかしいだけ醸すんですけどもう
みたいな声と船の方っていうのがちょっと聞こえて
でぐらいです
[音楽]
えっこの馬鹿な人に勧めていいものなんかわかんないんですけど
調べる感じ危険ということは一切ないみたいなんでまあ一種のトランス状態みたいな
ものなのでしょ
と何かホップやクレームがあるのであれば元つけると効果を考えた方にあのおっしゃっ
て下さいじゃあまたせた後は
[音楽]
me
あっひっ